ก็สวัสดีค่ะหน้าสวยครับนักเรียนสิครับนัก
เรียนเย้
โอเควันนี้กลับมาเจอกับ Theater ตี้ก็มา
เจอกับน้องรีเรียมไหมครับในช่องคอง
frenzel  can สิเบิ้ลไทยครับวันนี้อ้า
วันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันนี้วันอะไรครับวัน
นี้
วันนี้วันจันทร์ทำวัน
จันทร์เหรอใช่ครับอันนี้
โอเควันนี้วันจันทร์เมื่อวานวันอะไรครับ
เมื่อวานวันอาทิตย์เมื่อวานวันอาทิตย์นะ
ครับวันนี้วันจันทร์เนี่ยนะอะวันจันทร์
ใช่ไหมอ๋อเคเควันนี้วันจันทร์วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้วันที่เจ็ดอ้า
วันจันทร์ที่ 7 หรออ๋อแค่นะครับเดือนอะไร
ครับเดือนนี้เสือเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ค่ะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์นะครับโอเคเดือนกุมภาพันธ์อย่า
ลืมเดือนกุมภาพันธ์มีกี่วันครับ
มี
28 วันอ้าบางทีบางทีเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ก็จะ
มีก็จะมี 29 วันได้ครับอ่ะแต่ปีนี้ปีนี้
มีแค่ 28 วันนะอ่าโอเคเหตุแล้วปีนี้ปีนี้
ปีคศอะไรครับ
ขอศ.
2522 พระเทพปีคศ 2000  22 นะครับแล้วปีพ
ศอะไรครับ
พ.ต.ต.
2565 พ.ศ
2565 ครับโอเคอ่าปีนี้ปี 2020
มาแล้วปีสิหน้าปีหน้าปีอะไรครับ
ปีหน้าปี
2023  5 ใช้ค่ะปีหน้า
2023 โอเคแล้วปีที่แล้วล่ะปีที่แล้วปี
อะไรครับ
ปีที่แล้วปี
2021 ถ.ปีที่แล้ว 2,000 บาท 21 นะครับขอ
แค่โอเคอ่าปีนี้ 2,000
22 นะครับอ่ะต่อไปแล้วตอนนี้ตอนนี้เวลา
กี่โมงครับ
ตอนนี้
เที่ยงครึ่งค่ะ 5 เที่ยงครึ่ง OK หาคนไทย
เรียบเที่ยงครึ่งนะแต่เวลาเป็นสิบสองดีนะ
ครับ
12:30 นอ่ะคนไทยเรียก 12:30 เรียกสั้นๆ
เที่ยง 12:30 นโอเค 12:30 น 12:30 นเป็น
PM ใช่มั้ย
ใช่ว่าเทียน am10
12:30 นใช่ไหม
คะ
เป็น PM จะเป็นเที่ยงคืนเที่ยงคืนครึ่งน
ไป
เฮ้ยเหรอ
[เพลง]
แรง A  M  R
งงเปียตีกอล์ฟ
ที่ไทยจะมีเที่ยงวันกับเที่ยงคืนอ้าใช่
ครับถ้าเที่ยงวันเนี่ยจะมีพระอาทิตย์ใช่
ไหม
นะเนี่ยเที่ยงวันทั้งวันเที่ยงวันแล้วก็
บวกไปอีก 30 นาที
5  30 นาทีใช่ไหม
ใช่จังหวัดแต่ถ้าเป็นเที่ยวและมันยัง
ครึ่ง 12:30 นแล้วก็มีเที่ยงคืนหาจะเป็น
เที่ยงคืนก็จะเป็น 00 หรอ
24:00 น
30 นาทีแบบนี้หรอแล้วแบบนี้จะเป็นใช่ TM
หรือเป็น
เที่ยงคืนเป็น a.m. เงียบพี่ขอ
เป็น a.m. เที่ยงวันเป็น PM
ขึ้นไปนะเมื่อคืนครึ่งก็
0.30 เองนะ
โอเคเป็น mr.gay เท่านั้นตอนนี้ก็เป็น
ถ้าเป็น TM โอเคโอเคอ่ะไม่เป็นไรตอนนี้
12:30 นกินข้าวหรือยังครับน้องเรียมกิน
ข้าวหรือยังตอน 12:00 นยังไม่ได้กินอ่ะ
เฮียตีก็ยังไม่ได้กิน Hey เดี๋ยวเดี๋ยว
คุยกับนักเรียนเสร็จแล้วไปกินข้าวกันนะ
ครับได้โอเคโอเคๆแล้วก็เอาวันนี้เราคุย
กันเรื่องอะไรดีครับ
วันนี้เราคุยกันนะเรื่องวันวันใช่ไหมครับ
วันนี้เราจะมาคุยกันเรื่องวันอะเดี๋ยว
เบี้ยตี้นี่ใน 1  1 สัปดาห์หรือว่า 1
อาทิตย์เนี่ยอ้ามีกี่วันนะครับ
มี 7 วันค่ะค่ะมีเจ็บวันนี้มีวันหา
อาทิตย์วันจันทร์อ่ะเครียดที่ต้องนับซินะ
1 วันสอบอีก 3 วัน 4 วัน 5 วัน 6 วัน
แล้วก็ 7 วันหลัง k
5 น้องเรียมน้องเรียมรู้ไหมว่าคนไทยคน
ไทยมีสีของแต่ละวัน
ด้วยแต่ละวันมีสีไม่เหมือนกันนะ
ใช่ค่ะเดี๋ยวก็รู้ว่า
วันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธวันพฤหัสบดีวัน
สุดๆสาว 5 จะมีสีๆสีสีแบบนี้ไม่เหมือนกัน
ตายครับเราเรียกว่าสีสี
ประจำวัน 5 แสร้งครับสีประจำวันนะครับ
โอเคอ่าเดี๋ยวเรามาเริ่มกันเริ่มที่วัน
อาทิตย์ก่อนมีวันอาทิตย์ก่อนวันอาทิตย์สี
อะไรครับอ่ะ
และวันอาทิตย์สีแดง
ใส่ครับวันอาทิตย์สีแดงนะครับๆถ้านัก
เรียนมาประเทศไทยนักเรียนก็จะสังเกตว่า
วันอาทิตย์จะมีคนคนใส่เสื้อสีแดงเยอะๆ
เอ้อกว่าวันอื่นซ้ายอะมีคนบางคนแต่งตัว
ใส่เสื้อผ้าสีตามวัน
ได้สิงห์ใส่สีตามวันวันอาทิตย์สีแดงก็จะ
ใส่เสื้อใส่เสื้อสีแดงแดง 5 ใส่กับสำหรับ
คนไทยนะคนให้มีสีประจำวันแต่คนประเทศอื่น
ไม่รู้อาจจะไม่มีหรือมีไม่รู้อ่ะแต่คนไทย
วันอาทิตย์คือวันที่มีสีแดงประจำวัน
อาทิตย์สีประจําวันอาทิตย์นี่คือสีแดงใจ
ครับ
ทำไมต้องเป็นสีแดงค่ะทำไม
ไม่รู้ว่าทำไมแต่ว่าเออเราคนไทยเชื่อ
เรื่องแต่ละวันมีสีต่างๆกันมาตอนที่
ปาร์ตี้เรียนเพื่อที่ก็รู้ว่าวันอาทิตย์
สีแดงแล้วแต่เพื่อตีคิดเอาคิดเอาว่าวัน
อาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์มีสีแดงเพราะอะไรเดี๋ยว
พี่จะมาเฉลยหลังจากหลังจากวันสีของแต่ละ
วันตรงนี้อ้า
นักเรียนต้องรอรอรอดูอ่อนเยาว์
เราก็เชื่อเชื่อนะคะว่าใส่เสื้อสีแดงวัน
อาทิตย์แล้วจะโชคดีใจครับ
โอเคนะอันนี้วันอาทิตย์สีแดงใช่ไหมอ่ะต่อ
ไปวันจันทร์นะครับวันจันทร์วันอาทิตย์วัน
อาทิตย์แล้วก็เป็นวันจันทร์ใช่ไหมวันๆ
จันทร์สีอะไรครับ
สีประจำวันจันทร์ได้ครับ
เหลืองเยอะใช่ครับสีเหลืองนะสีเหลืองคือ
สีประจำวันจันทร์นะถ้านักเรียนมาประเทศ
ไทยแล้ววันจันทร์นักเรียนเห็นเห็นคนไทย
ใส่เสื้อสีเหลืองเยอะๆไม่ต้องแปลกใจก็
แปรงไดร์อ้ออ้วนอิอิวันนี้หวานจันทร์
ไปเขา
ตอนเอาเวลาน้องเรียมไปทำงานวันจันทร์น้อง
เรียมใส่เสื้อสีเหลืองไหม
เรียงเรียงไม่ได้คิดไม่ได้คิดวันจันทร์
วันอังคารวันพุธเรียนไม่ได้คิดแต่ว่าหลาย
คนหลายๆคิดอะไรบางคนบางคนก็ใส่ใส่ตามสี
อีก 3 วันบางคนก็ไม่สนใจใส่ใส่ที่อยากจะ
สายๆอะไหล่ก่อนๆนะครับ
โอเคอ้าวันจันทร์สีเหลืองแล้วต่อไปวัน
จันทร์แล้วก็มีวันอะไรอีกครับวันอาทิตย์
วันอังคารวันอังคารวันอังคารสีอะไรครับ
วันอังคารสีชมพู
ใส่แล้ววันอังคารสีชมพูโอเค
แล้ววันพุธล่ะครับวันพุธสีอะไร
วันพุธสีเขียวสีเขียวๆใช่ครับวันพุธสี
เขียวนะครับอาวันพุธสีเขียววันพฤหัสบดี
วันพฤหัสสีอะไรครับสีส้มมาสีส้มแค่สีส้ม
เป็นสีประจำวันพฤหัสบดี
หัวหน้าสีส้มนักเรียนจะมีบางคนก็พูดว่าสี
แสบขอสีแสดสีแสดเป็นชื่อเป็นชื่อเรียกสี
ส้มนะครับเมื่อทำใหม่นานมาแล้วสมัยโบราณ
เรียกสีแสด
แต่คนแก่คนแก่อุดสีแสด
พูดได้สีส้มๆตอนนี้พูดสีส้มนะครับอ่านัก
เรียนจะได้ยินสีส้มแต่ถ้านักเรียนได้ยิน
อาจมีคนบางคนพูดสีแสบ
แปลว่าสีต้นอ่ะช้าโอเคๆต้มโอเค
แล้วก็าอาร์อาร์มีอีกครับวันต่อไปวัน
พฤหัสแล้วก็วันศุกร์วันศุกร์วันศุกร์สี
อะไรครับ
สีฟ้า
แม้ว่าวันศุกร์สีฟ้าโอเค
หน้า R สีสุดท้ายครับวันสุดท้ายคือวัน
เสาร์ใช่ไหมมันเศร้าๆสีอะไรครับ
สีม่วงวันเสาร์สีม่วงไส้ครับน้านักเรียน
จำจำได้เหมือนคือวันไหนสีอะไรบ้างถ้าจำ
ไม่ได้อ่ะเดี๋ยวเบียร์ที่ทวนให้อีกรอบนึง
ควรให้อีกรอบนึงนะครับน้าโอเคเริ่มจากวัน
อาทิตย์ก่อนวันอาทิตย์
สีแดง
ตอนตอนเที่ยงตี้เรียนหนังสือตอนพี่เป็น
เด็กคุณครูให้พี่อาร์ตี้ท่องห้อง
ต้องวันนักเรียนได้ท่องไหมตอนเด็กๆนัก
เรียนเตรียมก็ท่องเหมือนกันค่ะเดี๋ยวก็หา
1วันอาทิตย์สีแดง 2 วันจันทร์ En  3 วัน
อังคารสีชมพู 4 วันพุธสีเขียว 5 เมื่อวัน
พฤหัสบดีสีแสด 6 วันศุกร์สีฟ้า 7 วัน
เสาร์สีม่วงเย้ 7 วันอาทิตย์ช่องช่องแบบ
นี้เหมือนกันอ่ะ
ตีป้อม
พฤหัสบดีสีส้ม
ว่าวัดพฤหัสบดีสีแสด
ฮ่าๆๆ
ขอสีแสบโอเค
แล้วก็ไม่
ทำไมต้องเรียกเราก็มีสีแบบนี้ค่ะอ่าทำไม
ต้องมีสีแบบนี้นะครับอ๋อชื่ออาเทศที่ต้อง
บอกก่อนว่าชื่อของวันชื่อของวันคนไทย
เรียกชื่อวันอาทิตย์จันทร์อังคารพุธหัด
ตามตามชื่อดวงดาวตามชื่อหวังดาวตามชื่อ
ดาวดูดวงดาวคืออะไรคะดาวคืออ้าเดี๋ยวพี่
ตี้วาดนะครับมี
อันนี้เป็นดวงอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมมีดวงอาทิตย์
แล้วก็มีอ่า
Wood นะมีดาวพุธดาวศุกร์ดาวโลกของเราอ่ะ
อันนี้อ้าวหมุนรอบดวงอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมอ่า
อยู่ในจักรวาล
คนไทยเรียกชื่อตามวัน
นี้คือชื่อของวันวันจันทร์วันอังคารวัน
พุธวันพฤหัสบดีหาใช่ครับในระบบคนไทยเรียก
มันว่าระบบสุริยะจักรวาล 6  5 เป็นพระ
ภาษาอังกฤษก็
เป็น Universe ใช่ไหมอาจเป็นระบบจักรวาล
เป็นจักรวาลของเราก็จะมีดาวต่างๆคนไทย
เรียกติดตามชื่อของดาว
ระบบสุริยะจักรวาลน่าจะเป็น Solar  System
ใช่ครับ Solar  System ได้ใช่ๆๆเพราะว่า
มีดวงอาทิตย์ดวงอาทิตย์เป็นเป็นสิ่งที่
อยู่ตรงกลางตรงต่างมีดวงอาทิตย์เป็นจุด
ศูนย์กลางของระบบ
อาหารอ๋อเคๆเดี๋ยวเราเริ่มมาทำความรู้จัก
กับดาวแต่ละดวงว่ามันชื่ออะไรแล้วมัน
เกี่ยวกับวันยังไงนะครับ
ถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวเราเริ่มที่ดวงแรกก่อนดาว
ดวงแรกก่อนดวงอาทิตย์
หน้าวันที่ 1  5 วันที่ 1 ที่น้องเรียม
ขัดข้องคือวันอะไรครับ 1 วันอาทิตย์วัน
อาทิตย์ใช่ไหมครับเพราะงั้นวันอาทิตย์ก็
มาจากมาจากดวงอาทิตย์อ่ะ
เหตุการณ์ดวงอาทิตย์ดวงอาทิตย์มีสีอะไร
ครับ
สีแดง
เอาแค่เพราะฉะนั้นวันอาทิตย์สีอะไรครับสี
แดงนางโอเค
[เพลง]
วันอาทิตย์มาจากชื่อของดวงอาทิตย์
หน้าคนไทยเรียกดวงอาทิตย์และครับต่อไปวัน
อะไรครับ
วันจันทร์จันทร์โอเควันจันทร์มาจากดวง
อะไรครับดวงจันทร์วงษ์จันทร์ใจครับอ่าดวง
จันทร์โอเคหน้าปกติแล้วคนคนไทยก็จะเห็น
ดวงจันทร์เป็นสีเหลืองตอนกลางคืนชายแต่
รูปนี้เพียงติไม่มีรูปสีเหลืองจะเอา
รูปดวงจันทร์มาหน้า
โอเคอ้าว
อาร์วันจันทร์น่ะก็เรียกมาจากนี่คือของ
ดวงจันทร์นะดวงนี้จะดาวดวงนี้เป็นดวง
จันทร์ก็คือวันจันทร์นะครับชื่อเหมือนกัน
นะครับอ่ะต่อไปวันอะไรครับวันจันทร์สี
เหลืองวันจันทร์ตา
3 วันอังคารวันอังคารนะครับวันอังคาร
เป็นดาวเดาอะไร
ดาวอังคารครับดาวอังคารกับดาวอังคาร
แต่เดาทานไม่ไม่ได้ P สีชมพูได้มั้ย
โอเคอาหารที่เป็นยาว
ขายเสียเวลามองไกลไกลๆดาวอังคารจะอยู่ไกล
ดาวอังคารถ้าเป็นภาษาอังกฤษภาษาอังกฤษ
เรียกอะไรครับ
เมื่อไรคะมาดาวอังคารมาตายครับดาวคนไทย
เรียกดาวอังคารแล้วอังคารก็ได้ครับอ่ามา
ดาวอังคารอ่ะ
ต่อไปอ่ามีวันอังคารแล้วต่อไปเป็นวันวัน
พุธวันพุธ
สีเขียวนะครับอ่าดาวพุธเป็นสีเขียว
อ้าวันพุธวันพุธก็คือภาษาอังกฤษเรียกอะ
Mercury คนไทยเรียกดาวพุธดาวพุธดาวๆก็มา
จากอ่ามาเป็นชื่อของวันเป็นวันพุธวันพุธๆ
มาจากดาวพุธ Mercury ดาวพุธนะครับน้า
ต่อไปนะครับดาวต่อไปเป็นวันต่อไป
ถ้าวันพฤหัส 5 นี่ครับวันพฤหัสบดีใช่ครับ
วันพฤหัสบดีมาจากดาวพฤหัสบดีคนไทยเรียก
ดาวพฤหัสบดีนะครับภาษาอังกฤษเรียกจุด
555 จูปิเตอร์เป็นดาวพฤหัสบดีนะครับอ่า
วันพฤหัสแล้วก็มีวันศุกร์ใช่ไหมใช่ถูก
กล่าวว่าศุกร์ก็มาจากดาวศุกร์ดาวศุกร์นะ
ครับ
คนไทยเรียกดาวศุกร์ภาษาอังกฤษเรียก Venus
ดาววีนัสคือคือดาวศุกร์เหมือนกันคนไทย
เรียกดาวศุกร์ภาษาอังกฤษเรียก Venus ดาว
ศุกร์โอเคหน้าวันศุกร์วันสุขใจครับเป็น
ดาวศุกร์นะครับอ่ะแล้วสุดท้ายวันสุดท้าย
ครับ
วันเสาร์วันเสาร์นี่ครับวันเสาร์ก็คือดาว
ดาวเสาร์ 5 ภาษาอังกฤษก็เรียกก็เรียก
คล้ายๆกันภาษาอังกฤษเรียกเป็นวันเสาร์
เป็น Saturday ใช่ไหมอันนี้ก็ดาวแซทเทิล
อ่ะดาวเสาร์ที่เหมือนแต่คนไทยก็เรียกวัน
เสาร์
5 สาวตายครับอ้า
และนี่ก็คือ
จะให้ความรู้สึกน้องเรียมได้ความรู้นัก
เรียนคือเรียนได้ความรู้ด้วยไหมนักเรียน
ได้รู้ว่าวันอาทิตย์ใส่เสื้อสีแดงแห่งตัว
โอเค
โอเคอ้าววันนี้วันนี้เราก็เรียนเรื่องวัน
กันได้ไหมอ่ามีวันอาทิตย์วันจันทร์อ่ะวัน
อังคารวันพุธพฤหัสศุกร์เสาร์มาจากชื่อดาว
นะดาวอ้าตาลอื่นอ่ะมูล
การสอนคลานอาม่าจะวันพุธพฤหัสศุกร์เสาร์
อะแล้วก็มีสีประจำวันด้วย
ใช้ครับโอเคถ้าเพื่อนจำไม่ได้คู่กรรมไม่
ได้วันไหนสีอะไรย้อนกลับไปดูยอมขับไปดู
วีดีโอใหม่นะครับครัวเตี้ยจิให้ทวนแล้ว
ไม่ทวน
เพียงคิดว่าพี่อาตี้จะบอกให้นักเรียนเข้า
ห้องครึ่งวันอ๋อ
ที่ 1 ท่องเราท่องไว้แล้วท่องไว้แล้วใน
ยูโรกลับไปดูต่อไปต้องได้นะครับโอเคอ้า
วันนี้เราหมดเวลาแล้วครับเดี๋ยวต้องลานัก
เรียนไปก่อนนะครับวันนี้แล้วเดี๋ยวคราว
หน้ากลับมาเจอกันในอ้อเที่ยงครึ่งแล้วใช่
ไหมต้องไปกินข้าวแล้วเดี๋ยวพี่อาร์ตี้กับ
ใกล้ไปกินข้าวก่อนนะครับ
ใช่ค่ะสำหรับวันนี้ต้องลาทุกคนไปก่อนค่ะ
ครับผมจะไปกันนะคะเจอกันใหม่สวัสดีครับ
นักเรียนบ๊ายบายที่มี
ม.ค